اريد ان ابدا من حيث ركز صهيب بشكل على
خان يونس نشر لواء من جانب اسرائيل في هذه
المنطقه ما الذي
يعنيه ليلى اصلا في هذه المنطقه هناك
اربعه الويه تقاتل ولواء لتامين الحمايه
واللوجستيه اضافه لواء قد يكون له عده
مؤشرات واحد ان هناك تعث ثر في العمليات
العسكريه اثنين ان الخسائر كبيره ثلاثه
تسريع العمليه وكانه هناك وقت معين لتنفيذ
او محاوله
تطويق خانيونس ولكن الاهم هو ما يجري في
الوسط ليى يعني في وسط القطاع حول
المخيمات الهدف الاسرائيلي دائما هو ضرب
الكتائب او كتائب المقاومه وبالتحديد
القسام في هذه المنطقه لانزال قدرتها على
القتال لانها لم تشتبك كما الشمال وكما
خانيونس اثنين لمنع اطلاق الصواريخ وهذا
الهاجس الاكبر سيكون في المرحله القادمه
او الثالثه التي يتحدث عنها يعني الجيش
الاسرائيلي ثلاثه هي حمايه خلفيه ومجنه
القوات التي تقاتل حول خانيونس فاذا هناك
خطه استراتيجيه كبيره كل مؤشر تكتيكي على
الارض له معنى بالبزل كما يقال هذه الخطه
مكونه من ثلاثه بنود كما اشرت كم من الوقت
تحتاج فعلا
لتحقيقها اولا يعني ليلى يقول كلاوز فيتس
كل شيء في الحرب بسيط وابسط شيء فيها معقد
جدا جدا جدا كم تامل الاسرائيلي ان ينتهي
من شمال غزه وها هو اليوم 82 يوم على
العمليات العسكريه مع خسائر وصلت الى اربع
498 مجموع القتلى من جنود وعسكر وحتى الان
لا يزال لا لا يزل يعني ليس قادرا على
يمكن قادرا على التقدم ولكن ليس قادر على
السيطره فاذا هذا الامر له علاقه بعده
امور اولا الاسرائيلي يقاتل ضد عدوين
بالنسبه له المقاومه وعامل الوقت اثنين
عامل الضغط الداخلي ثلاثه عامل قدره
المقاومه على الصمود وبالتالي انزال ربح
الوقت وانزال اكبر عدد من القتلى
والاستنزاف على فتره طويله وخان يونس لن
تكون نزه حتى الشمال ليس نزه ولكن خان
يونس مختلفه بمساحتها بقدرتها وحتى بطريقه
استعمال اسلحه جديده يعني اليوم عندما
نتحدث بدا ادخال اسلحه جديده سلاح
الكورنيت تحدثنا عنه الاسبوع الفائد ضد
الهامفي اليوم نتحدث عن الصاروخ سام 18
لواف والطواف تعتر 18 والطواف تعتبر جزء
اساسي من هذه العمليه ويخطئ ليلى من يقول
ان الاسرائيلي لم يتدرب على هذه العمليه
هذا رئيس الاركان الحالي له عقيده عسكريه
معينه تقوم على تدريب الجيش الاسرائيلي
على القتال التقليدي وبالتالي القتال
الهجين والقتال الهجين ليلى يقوم على
المشاه المدرعات من دبابات وناقلات جند من
هندسه من مسيرات ومن طائرات ومن طائرات
هليكوبتر من هنا طلب اسرائيل مزيد من
الطائرات الاباتشي طيب من خلال الفيديوهات
التي نشرت اليوم من جانب القسام تحديدا هل
ترى نوعيه
جديده روح جديده ربما في هذه الفيديوهات
لم تلحظها من قبل هل هناك شيء جديد فيها
يستوقفك
ليلى هذا هذا هذا هذا النوع من القتال
يعني نحن نقول ان القسام والمقاومه تصورت
لانها تعي المكان تعي الزمان وتستطلع
ولديها استعلام تكتيكي وهي لا تبحث عن
معركه فاصله بين جيشين تقليديين هي تقاتل
بنقاط القوه الخاصه فيها يجب على
الاسرائيلي ان يربح اذا اراد ان يربح عليه
ان يدخل واذا دخل الى مناطق هذه يصبح هدفا
سهلا وهناك كثره من الاهداف الاسرائيليه
يعني لا يمكن المناوره بدبابه بشارع بسيط
الشباك هو مركز للقنص حتى المبنى المدمر
ليلى يعتبر مبنى يعتبر متراس ومخ للمقاوم
الشيء الجديد هو راحه التنفيذ وحتى
الاوامر والقياده والسيطره هي شفهيه يعني
اليوم عندك حريه عمل ليس هناك من مركزيه
في هذا القتال حريه عمل والتنفيذ كلما
توفر الهدف